e poi vi chiedete come noi ci guarda
quasi 4 milioni di iscritti faccia i
video da tanti ragazzi video questo
nuovo video sono fa vj oggi siamo video
un po particolari deciso di sfidare
esterni adamson che un gioco di carte
superfigo le regole sono molto semplici
devi portare il suo eroe che è quello di
sopra il mio e quello 18 a vita a 0 il
primo che riesce a battere l'errore
dell'avversario ha portato a zero di
vita a vincere è stata la sfida
all'ultimo sangue ragazzi ve lo giuro
buona visione sfida del secolo hesl
allora facciamo che io pago fuso il mago
solo sai usare il tuorlo tutto è bello
che il mio personaggio maledetto è
quello di stefano alla barba grossa
facciamo così ci mettete su più belle
trame ben vorrei mettere l'ormone di
mara dai dai
ma è così ma tanto non usi e lea ed ipad
no ancora una perla delle baronie che
presto farà una brutta fine
spero
ecco l'attacco prezzo di un laido va
bene e adesso le diamo ai ha mai ragione
era già allora facciamo che io ho una
varietà di carte in mano che sono
spaventose preso in pieno ora parte il
raggio hanno colpito nola ma non cela il
segreto tanto non c'è poi avere non ce
l'hai o non ce l'hai
bene invece ce l'ha sicuramente sarà
penali che mi contrasta la magia ma
perché mai quella che copia il servitore
quella che controllava [ __ ] volevi si
guarda che faccia attenzione a loro
adesso mettiamo l'anima
prendiamo l'altra adesso aspetta aspetta
facevo anche così con pescare in ferro
[Musica]
in ferro non lo pescato quanta merda e
rozzano erano più carte in mano giocato
tutto più capito ma io penso adesso
dipende la più veloce il tuo mazzo se
persino araba che mi leva tuta è un
mazzo ora e prego vede che non muore
[Musica]
sono battuto raga ora che sono tutte le
carte a aspetta 48 solo una catodici 12
3 14 stai contando se hai vinto si
ammazza non ho vinto a maggio pure
[Musica]
a me di farmi trasporti interni sono
riusciti dai dai cazzo detto questa è
l'unica cosa che posso fare se mela
contrasti o perso porca put per ora
bella mossa fame addirittura reja è un
pezzo non posso farci niente
ho pescato bene ho pescato bene pazzo
sciamano weiss shrek
io già partito so devo uccidere con lo
scià merda ma hanno il fiume perché
crepe che perde lo sai che la pelle
dello sciamano del vicino è sempre più
verde
mannaggia la pupazza tra dieci posso
giocarla vice la regia che hai passato e
con tre mesi erano interessante adesso
io mi sa che pesco un abuso bravi solo a
[ __ ] per usare per lo show che dito
nella nota fano stronzetto digitali
porca [ __ ] e lo farà così infatti
quella carta li avrebbe avuto giocarla
per contusioni è per forza amica 26
abbiamo iniziato 56 contro la caccia e
devo fare perché devo campioni affanculo
va beh potrei giocare queste tranquillo
dai pesco fisco misco buona giornata la
moglie vide diventerà sia dal nas
giocherò così anche basta a mischiare le
carte bastano
o o di studio mi sa che devo fare no no
non ce l'hai
ma quella è un'altra ex
[Applauso]
certo che non si pensa al gove lo perché
culo tra la dai dai dai dai premi è
chiusa estremi rimedi
noi che siamo così quella che ebbe devo
farlo
no non quella che lascerà tutti non
quella che lascerà tutti devo farlo no
questo è molto buono non hai più ex
quindi sto tranquillo involuzione ma
quello vecchio
dai dai concludete mostriciattoli smurf
la notte 15 di vita 33 i pesci pescati
fammi pensare dio per il tannino mi vai
l'ostello funziona sta cazzona scenari
nuovi grado menis dai che il rotolino di
merda lì
va bene va bene ci sta non è un problema
dai dispacci stefani pesco fisco ancora
basta pescare ai problemi vedo che ogni
tanto pesco qualcosa di utile
i cazzi peccato che si chiama the map e
basta fatti danni
mai mai mai mai mai ok abbiamo il
cocktail aspetta non sta contando penso
che la soluzione a tutto dalle mie
ponderare ami bomber ha quasi finito il
tempo sito
così forte e bella no no no no dai
programmi nota ai porca [ __ ]
per adesso
l'unica carta che non permette a venire
non jackson non potevo farlo adesso non
pensava e sereno jackson è morto sono
morte in forma anzi sono adesso pensando
sto pensando a 20 anni e sto pensando
perché non lo capisco giocato ma le mie
carte e non volevano fare milioni per
ford è successo a lei lo sa dov'è
arrivato a tutti quanti e le valgono a
tutti sbagliano errore clamoroso
pensando nel caso la pina merito di
perdere quello distrugge questo poi io
io questo è un pagano 3 lo ha pagato 5
sono informare a dio
che palle r per forza fare così e così
no non quello magico non quello mangiava
gelo e rabbia sono pure fatto male alla
mano
[Musica]
accettato la scioccato ragazzi va bene
tu stai scherzando col fuoco fa vigente
egitto falli j tu stai scherzando col
fuoco sto concentrando vai bene andato
quel coso sento nel mio marzo da
telethon mazzo se non questo non lo
accetto
inutile cascato fortunatamente partita
veramente incasinata raga porca vacca
[Musica]
ahi ahi barba bronzea lo mandiamo a
[ __ ] ei piccoli con cielo di là
un gela di là
poi facciamo questo e qualcosa o rissa
anche palle con la carta dio sai a sto
punto [ __ ] se metti adesso un'arma
di spicco nel culo 22 ore che tengo in
mano sta carta
ok però ancora vivo che era polare l'età
orissa
ti porto in tomba sta partita a vicenza
ehi ma sempre quello da lì ma di chi è
un bel punto
[Musica]
non so se mi conveniva fare così o
attaccarti detto che ti dico dai è
finito il ragazzo che si chiama già la
chimica è fortissima ce lo aiuterà di
una bomba questo si possa verificare
senza problemi antichi questo ma qui
questo costituzione questo va in faccia
e qui abbiamo un classico 6 6 agosto due
registi
dai dai dai ti prego non fargli pescare
le carte e mi bastano per piacere bene
ho la soluzione più per quei due non è
un problema che basta a produrre non ci
credo ma questa non la puoi vincere favi
questo di studio
cazzo me ne frega da contorno midop 7 di
armaturati congelato
[Musica]
molto grave perché armature allora però
in che ti fa cantare su madonna lo giuro
che ti ammazzo con la donna è buttata
giù costavano ecco la donna la
scavatrice bellissima
serve un cazzo e pozioni la magia tutto
bello tutto finirà bene va bene ma temo
casuale sono provocazioni borsa dai
meritata melissa satta il livello era
potuto fare più nulla meritata e quindi
ragazzi questa era la doppia sfida di
oggi su alto non è stato guido un po
diverso perché avevo giocato un
videogame vero questo un vero videogioco
diversamente da quelli che faccio di
solito fatemi sapere se ne molette altri
perché capisco che magari può essere un
po di nicchia o di minchia mode2 ei
ragazzi spero che questo vi sia piaciuto
cosa bella è anche visto che come
rifiutata l'iscrizione genere tipica ci
mettiamo un prossimo video e sono in
bagno quindi chiudo con gli haters
ragazzi
[Musica]